[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ضيفوا حلقه الليله اتم بالكاد
عقده الرابع لكنه بالرغم من ذلك صاحب
انتاج رصيد وغزير ومحاضر في عدد من كبريات
الجامعات في امريكا واوروبا والمؤرخ
والباحث السياسي الفلسطيني الدكتور عبد
الرزاق التكريتي الذي ولد في العاصمه
الاردنيه عمان لاسره عروبيه الفكر والهوى
تعود جذوره الى مدينه حيفا الفلسطينيه
يعمل التكريتي استاذا لكرسي التاريخ
العربي الحديث في جامعه هيوستن امريكيه
المرموقه كما انه مؤسس ومدير مركز
الدراسات العربيه في الجامعه نفسها شغف
التكريت بالسياسه يعلله بولادته عام
1981 التي جاءت متزامنه مع فواجع حلت
بالامه العربيه وفق تعبيره ابتداء من
الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه فالاشتياح
الاسرائيلي لبيروت ثم الانتفاضه
الفلسطينيه الاولى وبعدها اتفاقيه
حصلت تكريت على درجه الدكتوراه عن اطروحته
التي حملت ظفار ثوره الرياح الموسميه
والتي ارخ فيها
لثوره الظفار الشهيره في عمان حيث سجلت
تاثيرات الفاعله لهذه الثوره في بناء
الدوله الحديثه في سلطنه عمان رغم الاستار
السميكه التي حاولت تغطيه اثار تلك الثوره
على بنيه المجتمع والدوله اطروحه التكريتي
عن ثوره الضفار حصدت جوائز علميه
واكاديميه معتبره على راسها جائزه ماركير
من مؤسسه دراسات الشرق الاوسط واشاره
التقدير من مجتمع الصداقه الكويتي
البريطاني في جامعه كامبردج عام 2014
لدراسات الشرق الاوسط عدا عن جوائز اخرى
التوجه الفكري لاسره التكريتي ترك اثره
على الابن فبرز اسمه في حقل النضال
السياسي المناهض الصهيونيه في الغرب كما
بات احد المنظرين الاكاديميين والنشطاء
السياسيين في حمله المقاطعه مقاطعه
البضائع الاسرائيليه الشهيره pdf فضلا عن
تراوسه مجلس اداره مركز مسارات لابحاث
السياسات والدراسات الاستراتيجيه مشاهدينا
الكرام التقي الليله باكاديميه ومؤرخ شاب
برزه في الساحات الاكاديميه الغربيه
الدكتور عبد الرزاق التاجيريتي ضيف هذه
الحلقه من المقابله فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا دكتور سعيد جدا بوجودك ضيف في
المقابله الاشياء اللافته لما قرات لك اول
مره توقعت اني التقي مع رجل كبير في السن
فتفاجئت بانك انت مواليد 81 يعني سيره
اكاديميه طويله وذاخره وانتاج ايضا علمي
وثقافي
مميز للغايه في تفاجات انه انه الدكتور
عبد الرزاق التكريتي ومواليد عام 1981
وانا سعيد جدا بوجودك اهلا وسهلا انت
دكتور من مواليد عمان
وانت من مواليد ثم علاقه مع الكويت اظن
تخص الوالد الوالد ولد في الكويت وجدي بعد
نكبه فلسطين في الواقع ذهب بدايه الى دمشق
ثم الى الكويت
بعد اذنك همم هذه الصله العائليه مع ال
همم الجزيره العربيه والخليج ابتدات همم
هذا كان ربما مبررا ان تكون رساله
الدكتوره ايضا عن ان انذار عن جانب من
الجزيره العربيه الارتباط العائلي
كان يلعب دورا في هذا السؤال ولكن
المبررات اخرى بالنسبه لاختيار موضوع
سنتحدث عنها في اي اسره ولد الدكتوره عبد
الرزاق تكريت هل اسره مسيسه مثقفه يعني
همم تنشغل بالسياسه ام اسره فلسطينيه
لديها قضيه مركزيه لكنها غير مسيسه
بالكامل يعني من جهه الام كان هناك تاثير
اكاديمي كبير انا جدي كان همم من اوائل
الحاصلين على شهاده الدكتوراه في همم في
الاردن وفلسطين لامك الدكتور سليم الناسف
لعب دورا كبيرا في حياتي وفي التاثير
الاكاديمي يعني فانا كنت من الهزيمه
ولازمه في الصغار همم اوقات كثيره همم في
مرحله التقاعده لم يكن يحب ان يختلط بكثير
من الناس ولكنه كان يحب
همم احد يحفاده الذين يرافقونه
كانت كبيره وزاخره بالكتب مع انه متخصص
علوم كان هو متخصص في مجال همم الكيمياء
الحيويه وخاصه همم من ناحيه الزراعه همم
بتطبيقاتها الزراعيه ولكنه كان يقرا
الروايات والتاريخ
وتاثرت به كثير همم هو بالواقع كان عميد
كليه خضوري زراعيه وهي اول همم كليه
زراعيه في الاردن وفلسطين يعني كانت هي
المكان الوحيد الذي يمكن ان تحصل به
تعليما همم
على مستوى كليه بعد انتهاء الدراسه في
فتره
الانتداب والسنين الاولى
ذهبت الى كندا اولا او الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه همم ذهبته همم بالمرحله
الثانويه نهايتها في همم بريطانيا اخر
سنتين من المرحله الثانويه العامه
بدات المرحله همم في كندا همم باكملته همم
البكالوريوس في جامعه في كندا ومن ثم
الماجستير في جامعه يورك ايضا في تورنتو
همم ومن ثم توجهت الى اوكسفورد لاكمالي
سعاده الدكتور في العالم الغربي الحقيقي
في كندا في بريطانيا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه معاقل ال- ال- الغربيه الرئيسيه
ايضا امر لافت لما نقول التكريتي ايضا
يذهب ذهننا الى العراق فمعظم الشباب الذي
كنت اتحدث معهم او الذين كانوا يتحدثون عن
عبد الرزاز عبد الرزاق التكريسي كانوا
يتخيلون انه عراقي الاسره لها ارتباط من
العراق ام ماذا يعني همم قصه اسرتنا هي
قصه همم الهلال الخصيب العراق وبلاد الشام
همم وهي قصه الوطن العربي اذا حسبت ذهب
بالعربيه
[موسيقى]
تموا بشكل كبير في بدايه القرن العشرين في
نهايه العهد العثماني همم نتيجه لوجود
ميناء طبيعيه فيها ف
وهناك تزوج من همم من ابنه عائله هيفاءويه
[موسيقى]
اخت همم زعيم حيفا في تلك الفتره السياسي
انت سالتني عن الخلفيه السياسيه الحج
ابراهيم هو همم تزوج من اخته فبالتالي جدي
لوالدي كانت بيئته همم الاولى همم الا
انني لم اعصر فهو قد توفي قبله لكن
بالجينات تنتقل ههه
لفتني ايضا همم حينما سالت في في برنامج
الاذاعي حول لماذا التاريخ
والحقيقه انه اجابتك اجابه تنسحب على كل
مواطن عربي في كل حكم زمنيه ربما في المئه
سنه او 200 سنه الاخيره تقول لنا همم 81
بعدها حدث اجتياح بيروت الحرب العراقيه
الايرانيه الانتفاضه الفلسطينيه الاولى
بعد ذلك غزوه الكويت والانهيار العربي
بشكل كبير بعد ذلك اوسلو مدريد
والتحول الكبير الحدث في مسار القضيه
الفلسطينيه يعني شاب صغير مهموم بشكل كبير
جدا صحيح صحيح همم انا ابتدات دراسه
التاريخ منذ عمر خمس سنوات
كنت احب القراءه بشكل كبير
اي منطقه في التاريخ
متعلق بفلسطين ام تاريخ العرب
والدتي همم مربيه فاضله واستاذ مهمه في
الاردن المعروفه في الاردن همم المستوى
المدارس الثانويه معلمه معلمه اسمها سهى
اسف همم هي همم كانت تهتم كثيرا في مجال
القراءه وكنت اذهب الى مكتبتها مكتبه
كبيره همم اقرا روايات تاريخيه يعني مثلا
تونس الحرب والسلام كنت كل سنه اقراها ههه
هناك اشياء مشتركه كمان منذ الصغر مجموعه
كبيره من الروايات التي فيها بعد تاريخي
او التي كتبت في القرن التاسع عشر يعني
انا كنت احب روايات الروسيه همم
ولكن هناك نقاش دوستيا ام تلستوي
في التاريخ اعتقادك اولا محبه في قراءه
التاريخ ثانيا تعتقد انه انه تم كوارث
وحوادث كبيره جعلتك اسير لتلك المرحله همم
صحيح ولكن انا كنت اسيرا في مرحله الصغار
همم في التاريخ الاسلامي المبكر ومن ثم
عندما اصبحت مؤرخالست التاريخ المعاصر
اعتقد هذا لها علاقه بطبيعه الكتب
الموجوده للناس الناشئه همم في تلك الفتره
يعني انا همم عندما كنت صغيرا انا اقرا
همم كتب من مثل سلسله الناجحون مثلا سلسله
الخالده انا نعتبر الواقع اجيال القادمه
اتمنى ان تعود مثل هذه الكتب
هل لعبد الرزاق التكريتي ملمح ايدولوجي
معين يعني تشكلت ايدلوجين في اتجاهات
الفكريه السياسيه القائمه في المنطقه
العربيه يعني طبعا الايديولوجيا لابد ان
تؤثر بك ولكن انا اعتبر ارتباطي همم
ارتباطن بالمسائل همم ومحاوله ايجاد حلول
ومخارج لها فنحن انا تربيت في عصر همم
انهارت اغلب الاحزاب الايديولوجيه المنظمه
في الوطن العربي
والتيارات الاسلاميه كانت موجوده همم ولكن
انا لم انت همم اليها عندما كنت صغيرا كنت
متاثرا بالفكر الاسلامي طبعا في فتره
الصغار همم انا والدي مر في مرحله تدين
قويه في الثمانينات مثل مثل الكثير من
ابناء همم ودخلت في هذا الجوله فتره ولكن
هذا كان في الطفوله همم
لم استمر به بالناحيه السياسيه
انا ذهبت الى جانب اخر ذهبت الى جانب
البحث عن الاشكاليات والبحث عن الحلول
لهذه الاشكاليه او فكريه هل تشعر انك قريب
من تيار قومي على سبيل المثالي بشكل
[موسيقى]
عداله الاجتماعيه اكيد يعني واعتقد ان
الناس سنجد في العصر القادم ان مساله
الاداه الاجتماعيه سوف تعود الى المنطقه
بقوه
والتيارات صحيح صحيح من هذا كان السؤال
هناك نقطه اناقشها بشكل مفصل لاحق لكنها
كلمه مفتاحيه حقيقه ذكرتها ايضا استعاده
التاريخ لماذا تبدو مساله استعاده ماذا
يعني اول استعاده التاريخ
تفترض انه قد فقد
او اختطف او غيب ايه وانا اعتقد ان كان
هناك من هذا كبير لتغييب التاريخ
واختطافها في بعض الاحيان همم تقصد المئه
عام الماضي لا انا اعتقد ان ان هذا الامر
حصل خلال همم 40 سنه الماضيه او ال 50 سنه
الماضيه يعني كان هناك ان اشكاليه كبيره
همم بعد تكون الدوله الحديثه عندنا في
المنطقه همم اصبح هناك برقيه قادره على
تغيب التاريخ وايضا همم
ظهرت هناك همم انتصارات للامبراطوريات
التي كانت مسيطره علينا
وبالتالي هذه الانتصارات فرضت الروايه
الرسميه
المسيطر عليها
الدكتور هي اول الروايه القوه المسيطره
الامبرياليه او ما قبل ذلك كانت الدوله
العثمانيه ثم القوه الاستعماريه
البريطانيه وغيرها ثم جاءت الانظمه التي
اعادت انتاج تاريخي موجودها ويعرفها ويبرر
لها وبالتالي نحن امام اي تاريخ تحديدا
الان حينما نقرا ماذا جرى امام اي تاريخ
انا برايي يجب ان نعود الى المسائل الى
المطروحه عندما نفكر في الرد على هذا
السؤال ان مساله السياده
هل السياده تكمل همم في الشعب هل تكون في
فئه حاكمه همم مقتصره على مجموعه من
العائلات او الافراد اما هل تكون في همم
العواصم الخارجيه همم لندن في السابق او
باريس
في العصر الحالي يعني همم اين تكون
السياده في المنطقه ثاني اشي عندك مساله
الجغرافيا يعني نحن هنا الان في الاردن
همم في منطقه كانت جزء من بلاد الشام
مرتبطه ارتباطا وثيقا فلسطين مرتبطه
ارتباطا وثيقا بسوريا بلبنان بالعراق
بالحجاز
همم
كيف رسمت هذه الخارطه همم بهذا الشكل الذي
يمزق المنطقه بشكل
تاسفي طبعا همم فعندك مساله الجغرافيا همم
لذلك اغلب الحركات السياسيه
في بلاد العربيه كان عليها ان تجيب على
هذه الاسئله هل سيكون توجهها واحتوي ماذا
سيكون توجهها قطري مثلا هل سيكون توجهها
همم مبني على فكره سياده الشعب او على
مجموعه من التحالفات مع الانظمه الموجوده
الانظمه ايضا كانت محاطه با كبيره
انا عندما اقرا تاريخ القرن العشرين
العربي
اجد بان هناك صراعا كبير على فكره همم
ارتباطنا في القوه ال- ال- الامبراطوريه
وهو صراع مستمر الى اليوم بشكل عام كان
هناك تيار محافظ
وليس بالضروره انه تيار يعني يخون او يعني
لا نحتاج ان اتهم بالعماله او الخيانه
لنفهم تصوراته يعني قد يكون بالتصور
الكثير من افراده انهم يمارسون الواقعيه
همم
الظرف الذي
في العالم حسب وجهه نظرهم همم هذه القوه
ليس لديك مطار من الارتباط بها
مصلحه ناتج
عن الارتباط ليس من مصلحتك الاستقلال اذا
بالاضافه الى مساله السياده ومساله
الجغرافيا هناك مساله الاستقلال وهي كانت
مطروح بقول
هذه القوه كانت تقول بان اي تيار يريد
استقلالا فعليا ومتهور لانه سوف يؤدي الى
اصطدام مع هذه القوه المسيطره
وبتعبير بعض هؤلاء الناس يعني انا اجد
ببعض الوثائق القديمه ولذلك بعضهم يقول لك
الانجليز اسيادنا مثلا يستعملون هذه
الكلمه يعني وبارتياح كبير وارتياح كبير
لان هذا الواقع الموجود فيه ليس لانه همم
يعني همم
قوه امبراطوريه قويه جدا مهيمنه على شعوب
ااه لا يتوفر لديه القدرات العسكريه
والاقتصاديه
فكره حول الحركه حول الحركه النظاليه التي
كانت سائده في العالم العرب وهي حركه كانت
محمله بمشاعر حقيقيه وقويه جاءت تغير مثل
هذا الواقع لكن هل كانت حركات واعيه قادره
على تفكيك هذه الروايات المهمه والسائده
بحيث
على فكره ان الوعي اولا ثم التغيير ام ان
لم تكن يعني على هذا على هذه الدرجه من
الوعد انا اعتقد انا المساله ليست مساله
وعي فقط هذه الحركات همم كان عندها بعض
الوعي وبعضها كالمتقدما جدا بوعيه وبعضها
كان متقدما بوعيه على واقعه الاجتماعي
وانا اعتقد انها الخلل يكمن في في هذه
الامر في كثير من الاحياء يعني
انا كتبت اول كتاب لي على ثوره الظفار
تستعمل افكار هي خلاصه همم ارقى افكار
طورت في مجتمعات همم واجهت الثوره
الصناعيه ووجدت كثير من الامور يعني لما
لما تتكلم عن تحليل الطبقيه ولما تتكلم عن
النظريات سياده وافكار تحرريه
من هذا الامر
يعني راوي بنهايه المطافاسه وايضا في حاله
ظفار يعني هذه تحديدا همم
اغلب المجتمع في الجبال كان يعتمد على على
الراي وفي في المدن تجاره بسيطه جدا لماذا
كتبت عن ثوره الظفار الرياح الموسميه
واعدت قراءه هذه الحركه الهامه في تاريخ
الجزيره العربيه في تاريخ الامانه على
يعني على على وجه التحدي لماذا يعني
فلسطين
ومشاعره ووجدانه حتى دراساته وابحث حول
القضيه المركزيه وهي الاكثر اهميه ذهبت
الى ظهور صحيح انا انا اتجننت انا اكتب عن
فلسطين
وتجنبت ايضا ان اكتب عن الاردن بتعرف انا
فلسطيني واردني وممكن هذه بيئه مباشره همم
همم ولكن هذا لها علاقه بانني احمل الهم
الفلسطيني
بجو اليوميه يعني
انه اردت ايضا ان تكون اكاديميا باحثا
بعيدا عن عن قضيه تشغله بشكل يومي فكانها
اختبار لقدراتك البحثيه والعلميه وانت
تتخلص من علبه هذه القضيه اليوميه اردت ان
تكون باحثا اااه موضوعيا محيدا في مجال
الدكتوراه في مجال الدكتور هل الدكتور همم
صحيح وانا انتجت كتابا عن بلد احبها يعني
انا بالنسبه لي هذه مساله مهمه لان لا
اعتقد همم بان المؤرخ يمكن ان يكتب همم
بشكل دقيق عن مكان يكرهه يعني
لا احتاج ان اسالك عن ما هو السبب الذي
يدفعك لحب عمان وظفار ولكن اريد ان اسال
لماذا تحبه بشكل خاص سوف انت زرت عمان همم
بلد رائع بصراحه
وايضا فيه من تقاليد المقاومه وتقاليد همم
همم
الروح المحليه الموجوده هناك قويه جدا همم
اليوم همم قد لا تزيدها بنفس الاشكال ال-
ال- القديم ولكن تاريخ العماني تاريخ رائع
يعني اول
غزو كبير في المنطقه تم دحضه في عمان
طبعا غزوه البرتغاليه
الاكاديمي يعرف بان هذه لم تكن حركه مهديه
للاستعمار بمفهوم الحديث كانت يعني
ظهر الغزو البرتغالي لا يمكن فهمه من
المنظور القوميات اليوم نعم ولكنه كان فيه
جانب همم مثير الاهتمام جدا
وطبيعه المسلمين طبعا ظفار لها خصوصيه
ايضا خاصه بها ولها ارتباطات همم اخرى
يعني عميقه لها طبيعه مميزه هذه منطقه همم
تاتيها الرياح الموسميه في في الجزيره
العربيه يعني عندك واحد كبيره فيها همم
اشجار همم وغابات انا دكتور قرات كثيرا عن
عن الثوره عن تاريخ وكانت كتب فيها
العاطفيه وطبعا هناك التاريخ ايضا الذي
ينظر من جانب السلطه والدوله اا في كتابك
وجدت حاله علميه بحثيه رصيد ما الجديد
الذي اضفته انا لا اريد ان اغص كثيرا في
تفاصيل كتاب نحتاج هذا لوحده الى لحلق ما
الجديد الذي اضافته دراستك في الدكتوراه
لثور الظفار وتاريخها ولفهمها انا اعتقد
بان اهم شيء هو ادخال نظره مفاهيميه
للموضوع بمعنى بمعنى الكثير من ال- ال-
التواريخ العربيه همم تقدم فقط همم
المعلومه همم ونحن بحاجه الى ان نذهب همم
الى زوم اخر وزو المفاهيم هلا ظفار انا
اخترتها جزئيا بالاضافه الى محبه لهذا
البلد لجغرافيه وتاريخه همم لانها ايضا
كانت تمثل عصاره مجموعه من التجارب
العربيه الثوريه في تلك الفتره همم ممكن
تحكي خلاصه كل هذه التجارب تجمعت بها يعني
فيها تاثير من اليمن
فيها تاثير من الثوره الفلسطينيه همم
وفيها تاثير من حركه القوميين للعرب وفيها
تاثير من الحركه الوطنيه في الكويت تاثير
كبير جدا شارك فيها كثير من الخليجيين من
البحرين من الكويت نحكي انه اسست في
الكويت
وهذا جانب يعني همم ضروري التفكير لانه
ايضا هناك بعض المؤرخين يعني ينسبونا
الثوره الى الرصاصه من شيخ القبلي في ظفار
لا هي النتائج حركه حديثه سياسيه من
العمال الظفريين تاثروا
متطور جدا سياسيا همم نسبه لتاريخ المنطقه
في تلك الفتره لانهم اختلطوا بشخصيات
كبيره مثل دكتور احمد الخطيب همم كانوا
يعملون في مؤسسات حديثه مثل همم شركه
النفط في الكويت همم متاثرين بالجنه همم
سياسي في حراك كبير الناصريه موجوده في
بدايه الحوار انه يعني اسقطت افكار كبرى
لمجتمعات مرت بثورات صناعيه ومراحل كثيره
على مجتمع همم لم يمر بهذه المراه اكثر
بساطه هذا كان يعني ما ما اثره على الواقع
في في السنوات الاخيره يعني الاثر على
الواقع همم هو همم لها علاقه ايضا
بالممارسات المناهضه لك لا لا يكفي ان
تكون انت موجود هناك
لتحقق الطموحات الكبيره التي تطرحها يعني
يجب ان تعرف ماذا قوتك عندما تريد ان تؤسس
لثوره مثل هذا النوع همم ويجب ان تتعامل
مع الجو المحلي الذي انت فيه يعني مثلا
الثوره كانت تطرح برامج كبيره مثلا حقوق
المراه
ومساله توزيع الميراث بشكل متساوي مساله
الاصلاح همم اصلاح الزراعي
ياتي لك مثلا احد المناظرين في الثوره
يقول لك هناك اخطاء موجود في الوفاء طبعا
هو يستعمل مفهوم
اتي من اوروبا بالضبط
شيوخ المحليين مثلا اليوم ما يملكون بعض
الاراضي طبعا اكثر من غيرهم ولكن ليسوا
يقطعين اقطعين بمفهوم الاكاديميه
دراستها بشكل يعني تاريخي ما هي الادوات
الحديثه التي استرد عليها انتاج هذه
الرساله والكتاب العام ايضا نشوف همم هناك
همم الادوات اللي فيه المفاهيميه هي الاهم
انا طبعا لا هي بحثيه لا شك انني همم
يعني تبات جميع الارشيفات
والمواد المتوفره همم لديه في تلك الفتره
الان ايضا توفرت مواد اكثر ول كان الاستاذ
جاء المزيد من الباحثين في الخوض بهذا
الموضوع همم ولكن في تلك الفتره انا
الرجاء يعتبر مصدر رئيسي معين رئيسي
في الانجليزي يعني كيف يمكن لباحث تاريخي
ان يميز في هذا الشيفوره هو بريطانيا لعب
رئيسي يعني هذا الارشيف من اوجده ويكاد
يكون المصدر الرئيسي للمعلومات من اوجده
هو المستفيد الاول من من كل الواقع الذي
كان قائما صحيح البريطاني هذا الارشيف هو
ارشيف من كان يدير الدوله وان كان يدير
الحرب على هذه الثوره همم فبالتالي فيك
كنز من المعلومات ولكن عندما تعالج
الارشيف هذا يجب ان تعالج بحذر يعني هناك
بعض المؤرخين ينقل الحرفيا على هذه
الاشياء هذا ليس همم تاريخا هذا عباره عن
تدوين ارشيفي اما همم
الحرفه التاريخيه تتطلب ان تعالج النص همم
بفكر النقدي في ايضا بفكر يضع همم كل لاعب
همم ضمن همم سياق اللعب يعني لابد ان تفهم
دوره ادوار اللاعبين ضروريه انما تقرا
مثلا ارشيف الانجليزي
الكثير من همم الوثائق تتحدث عن الثوار
بانهم بصفه الارهابيين والمتمثلين متمردين
وما الى ذلك همم انت لا تاخذ ما تقول هذه
الوثائق بهذا الشكل انت تقول همم اريد ان
افهم لماذا يسمونه
همم
يعني فتره جيده
للاسف لا يمكن ان تقوم ببحث ميدان لفترات
طويله في دولنا العربيه اليوم من هذا من
هذا الشكل
[موسيقى]
ليس سرا انا شبه الجزيره العربيه ظلت منذ
نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه مرورا بحقبه
الحرب البارده واصولا الى يومنا الحاضر
محور لصراع ثلاثه ايدولوجيات اساسيه هي
التيار القومي العربي واليسار الشيوعي
والاسلام الحركي وعلى غرار اي فكر سياسي
او مشروع عقائدي كان لهذه الهيدروجين
تفرعات وارتباطات بقوه اقليميه واخرى
دوليه كما كان لها التاثيرات مختلفه
ومتباينه على واقع هزيمه عام 67 تراجع
المد القومي العربي بين من حصر المد
اليسرى الشيوعي عقيبا انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي مطلع التسعينيات في حين اشتد عود
التيار الاسلامي بجناحيه السني والشيعي
مستفيدا من تهاوي المشروعات السابقه
وبعيدا عن خفوت نجم الحاله الاسلاميه بشكل
ملحوظ خلال السنوات القليله فاضيه ترك
المد القومي والناصري واليساري اثارا لا
تزال واضحه المعالم على تاريخ وثقافه اهل
المنطقه التي كان غالبيه اقدارها ترزح تحت
نير الاستعمار البريطاني فمن رحم
الاستعمار الذي نهب الخيرات والثروات ورسم
الحدود والخرائط كيف ما تراء له ولدت
حركات رفعت شعارات ذات صبغه تحرريه
ونضاليه وثوريه في اكثر من بقعه جغرافيه
لكن بقي الكثير من هذه الشعرات مجرد
الرصاصات يطلقها معسكر ضد المعسكر الاخر
[موسيقى]
هل تمت روايه شفويه باقيه يعني احنا من 65
يعني فتره طويله ليها 75 هل تمت روايه
شفويه يعول عليها باقي حتى الان
التغيرات والخوف هناك روايات شفويه ولكن
كان هناك تخوف شديد
يعني كان اغلب الثوار السابقين المشاركين
لا يودون الحديث على الكاميرا او التسجيل
او لا يريدون ذلك كانوا مستعدين همم جلسات
حواريه
وكانوا اكرموني بصراحه الكثير اكرمني همم
اعزموني على العشاء والغداء
الحديث العام ولكن همم المقابلات الجديه
فعلا همم كانت محدوده في الغرفه ما ان بعض
الشخصيات وانا همم استطيع ان اذكر همم
من توفى منها وليس همم يعني في بعض
الشخصيات التي لها الدوره المركزيه فعلا
مستعدين خليني اتحداك واعبر عن السلطه يا
دكتور اذا سمحت العب الدور الاخر لا اجيد
لعبه الحقيقه انه كان في صرامه بين حاله
الريع والرفاه والدوله النفضيه في الخليج
والدوله المستقره اللقائم على شرعيه ملكيه
او اميريه وراثيه وكان في الحاله الثوريه
الجمهوريه التي حدثت في اليمن طبعا في
العراق واسقطت الملكيه في سوريا في مصر في
ليبيا الاخيره الا يبدو ان عمان انقذت
نفسها بعدم نجاح مثل هذه الثوره وبالتالي
كان ممكن ينتظرها مصير يعني هل وصلت لي
مثل هذا الامر ام ان الافضل لم يحدث
بالنسبه للثوار في ظفار وانما حدث هو
الاسود يعني لو لو لو لو قرانا اليوم باثر
رجل نتيجه انا ارفض قراءه ال- ال- التاريخ
تبدا منها تعود همم الى الخلف همم وهو
يفترض بان التاريخ يسير بخط مستقيم يعني
لا تبع الرجال فيه ولا العوامل في التاريخ
كثيره ومتغيرات كثيره يعني همم نجاح ثوره
في مكان ما كان يمكن ان يؤثر على الخارقه
بشكل مختلف يعني تخيل انت لو نجحت الثوره
في في ظفار ماء نجاح في شمال عمان كان
ممكن ان يظهر لك نظام همم
له طابع همم اشتراكي في تلك الفتره طبعا
ولكن مع موارد نفطيه طيب هذا في اليمن
الاخرى
نفسيه يعني الغنى ليس مرتبط فقط الاداره
الجديده مصر غنيه العراقيه وفيها وفيها
موارد نفطيه العراق
العراق
الجزائر ايضا اخر كليه لانه انت تتعامل في
حاله العراق والجزائر ما شعريه استقلاليه
كبيره ولكن اا كانت تواجه اشكاليه بناء
دوله داخليه وفي حاله العراق كانت تواجه
انقسامات مجتمعيه وايضا باجل استراتيجيه
همم معقده بشكل كبير نرجع لاستعاده
التاريخ شو اهميه المدرسه
من اكبر الكوارث الذي اجدها همم استاذ علي
هو التعامل الغيبي مع التاريخ العربي
حاليا في الاوساط
هناك نظريات مؤامره كبيره هناك همم
تفكير بان همم العوامل التي تحصل في
المنطقه هي مجرد همم قوه في الخارج تتلعب
كما تريد هذا يؤدي الى انتكاسه في العقل
والفكر والممارسه ويعطل التغيير طبعا لانك
اذا اذا لم تستوعب واقعك بشكل دقيق وبشكل
مبني على همم معلومات دقيقه وتحليل ايضا
اييه متقدم
انت بالنهايه سوف تدخل في التعامل مع
واقعك بطريقه مهزومه من اساسي للقضيه
المركزيه العربيه التي يعني يؤمن بها كل
انسان عربي والتي يعني هي هي مركز الازمات
العربي القضيه الفلسطينيه قابلتها افيش
لاين وهناك ظاهره المؤرخين الجدد الذين
يحاولون اعاده قراءه او التاريخ
لوجود هذا الكلام المحتل وهذا كان
الصهيوني بشكل اخر كيف تنظر لي ظاهره
المؤرخ الجلد ما فيش لاين طبعا
هل قدم روايه تاريخيه
افضل مما كانت عليه الامور انا ارفض فكره
ان هناك تيار موحد اسمه المؤرخون الجدد
الاساسي يعني هو ما حصل هو ان هناك مجموعه
من الارتفاع الاسرائيليه تم اطلاقها في
بدايه الثمانينات ومجموعه من الباحثين
الاسرائيليين بدؤوا بالبحث به الدوله
العكس الكثير من الدول العربيه ام دوله
واثقه بنفسها وثقه من جوي هالداخلي طبعا
ااه طبعا طبعا لم تطلق جميع الوثائق واهم
الوثائق التي تعلق تتعلق في المجاز وما
الى ذلك همم لا نجده يعني
قام بها هؤلاء على الروايه التي كانت مهمه
وسائده هؤلاء همم
غير الروايته كليه لانه ترك الصهيونيه بعد
ان اكتشف هذه الوثائق وهذا الفرق بينه
وبين الاخر الاخرين همم ما فيش سلايم اخذ
موقفا معتدلا في البدايه وهذا له علاقه
همم ايضا الماده التي عالج هو كان يعالج
مساله علاقات الحركه الصهيونيه بالجوله
العربيه المحيط بها وخاصه بالاردن
فبالتالي له توجه همم يعني همم متعاطف مع
الجو الفلسطيني الا انه حتى فتره قريبه
كان محوما بفكره همم حل دولتين مثلا همم
ضمن حدود ال 67 طبعا الان نتيجه
الاسرائيلي همم سلايم غير مواقفها همم
الواقع صديق ويعتقد انه الان همم ابتدا
يدرك بان المساله جذريه اكثر
نفسها هل اقترب من من موضوع انه يقترب من
من زوج الى همم ولكن طبعا
رفض الصهيونيه بشكل كامل اتخذ موقف شجاع
وجذري
انا اعتبره اعتبره من من الناس الذي يجب
ان يكرموا اذا تحرك فلسطين
يعني اذا انت في جامعه عربيه مثلا من
الصعب ان تحصل على الوثائق الا اذا سافرت
الى الخارج هناك وثائق محليه موجوده ولكن
انت بحاجه لتفرغ اكاديمي لتذهب وانت
تتابعها عندنا اشكاليه في بنيه الجامعه
العربيه يعني ليس الجامعه بالمؤسسه
السياسيه ولكن جامعات الاكاديميه لا يوجد
هناك فتره تفرق كافيه للباحثين همم هناك
همم ارهاق لهم في كورسات تدريسيه وما الى
ذلك هناك عدم تقدير انت تعرف في الكثير من
جماعه من جامعه الكويت انت طبعا تعرف
الكويت بشكل
طبعا جامعه الكويت اليوم اذا انت مؤرخ في
جامعه الكويت
كتابا مثلا يعامل كما يعامل المقال يعني
مصلحتك ان تنشر مقالات وليس وليس كتب
مؤسسه الاكاديميه ليست مؤسسات تدفع لمشروع
لاعاده التاريخ يعني اقل من ذلك بكثير
اقصد الاكاديميين في الخارج الاكاديميين
في الخارج موجودين وفاعله يعني هناك اعاده
قراءه شامله اليوم تحصل على جو التاريخ
الفلسطيني انا طبعا واعالج الموضوع من من
ناحيه اعاده قراءه الثوره الفلسطينيه ومن
مجالي
نذهب ماذا تفعل بالضبط يعني شوف همم انا
تقريبا برايي يجب ان نقوم بتحرير الروايه
العربيه التاريخيه ككل ومنها ظفار ومنها
فلسطين ومنها الجزائريه تنتفخ الجميع من
فكره همم تاريخ الهزيمه الذي الذي نحن
نعيشه اذا اذا تنظر انت الى الى كل
الحركات التحرر في العالم في فترات
الهزائم يكتب التاريخ بشكل يختلف عن فقرات
الانتصار يعني اليوم ما يكتب عن مثلا ااا
قادت الحركات الثوريه العربيه همم
الاساسيين سوف يكون مختلفا لو تغيرت
الخارطه العربيه والمستقبل وحصل هناك
انتصار الذي ينظر اليه اليوم كفاشل يعني
هذه
على الروايه التاريخيه السائده ثاني شيء
هناك تركيز نحن عندنا في التاريخ الموجوده
على النخب وليس على
الادوار الشعبيه
والحركات همم
وهذا امر مؤسس يعني تاريخ ماشي دخل في
التاريخ الغربيه منذ الخمسينات والستينات
يعني ظهرت هناك طبعا المجموعه همم رخيصه
مهمين في بريطانيا ابتداء وانتشرت ايضا في
فرنسا
الشديد اليوم همم هناك المتابعين
للمسلسلات التركيه وما لذلك تعودوا لنا
هذه الافكار يعني السلاطين ولا هذا وهذا
هوس همم
الناس هذا التاريخ الذي تربينا عليه هو
تاريخ الخلفاء والسلاطين وما لا ذلك طيب
ماذا عن الشعب ماذا عن الحركات السياسيه
ماذا عن الانسان العادي ماذا عن المراه
الطبقات المهمه والفئات المهمه في المجتمع
يعني نحن نصف المجتمع عندنا لا نذكره
اساسا 10 سنوات
همم شفت شيء في الارشيف يعني يعول عليه
اشوف بريطاني خاصه انه هو الدوله التي
كانت مهمه شفت شيء وعول عليه في محاوله في
اعاده الروايه والتنقيته كما يجب هلا اول
بس تصحيح بسيط انا مش 10 سنوات
ههه يعني دراسه
صحيح
قريب الارشيف وقريب المرام
المجموعه من العسكريين البريطانيين وضباط
المخابرات وما الى ذلك همم
يتركونا اوراقهم في الاقصر هي مركز مهمله
في اعاده الروايه لانه تحرير الفكر وتحرير
الفهم التاريخ مساله رئيسيه فيها اي عمليه
تغيير صحيح هي هي مساله رئيسيه عندنا في
المنطقه اصلا وايضا مساله رئيسيه في
مواجهه التواريخ المكتوبه من المنظور
صهيوني واستعماري في الخارج يعني انا عندي
مهمه همم
كمرخ عربي في الخارج عندي مهمه مكافحه
روايه شرسه هدفها محوك ده فوقها استمرار
الاستقبال الموجود منطقه واستمرار السيطره
وموجود في المنطقه واستمرار الكوارث مثل
كارثه فلسطين وغيرها من الكوارث الموجوده
عندنا يعني انت عندك جو يدفا الى التفكك
المستمر وجزء من هذا الجو يعتمد على روايه
تقول بان همم ما تقوم به القوه الغربيه
كله مدفوعه
بالقيم الجيده والاخلاق وما الى ذلك وان
تكافئ قوه ظلاميه يعني سواء كانت شيعيه في
العصر الماضي او الاسلامي اليوم او ما الى
ذلك همم طبعا همم اما اهالي المنطقه عندنا
فيصفون بانهم مجموعه من الناس يعني ليس
لهم دور اصلا الذين
همم
الناس المعادين للغرب والمؤادين الاسرائيل
بلا اهداف منطقيه ولا ولا اسس طيب هذا هذا
لدينا هدم هذه مشكله ولا لها علاقه طبعا
في الجو الاكاديمي الغربي همم يعني همم
طبيعته هناك مؤسسه همم تاريخيه صهيونيه
لها وجود فيه هناك مؤسسه تاريخيه همم
عسكريه موجوده في هناك ارتباط بين الجيوش
في الغربيه والمؤسسات الاكاديميه هناك
ايضا مؤسسه سياسيه طبعا الدوله وزاره
الخارجيه الدوله لذلك تؤثر في في الجامعات
في الغرب كله هذا متصل فيه ولكن يعني في
الفتره الماضيه يعني والحق يقال همم ادوار
سعيد قدم خدمه كبيره همم يعني هائله لاهل
المنطقه عندما همم قام بنقد الاستشراق
جديده
جديده يعني همم وضع همم
الاكاديميين الغربيين امام المراه اراهم
منهم طيب الدكتور انت في حركه المقاطعه
مقاطعه همم
البضائع وكل شيء السجوني وانت ايضا من من
اسهموا في في ترسيخ مفهوم الامبرتايد
الفصل العنصري خلال العمل يعني جماعه كيف
تبدو مواجهه هذه الدوله الصهيونيه المحتله
اليوم في الغرب يعني ثمه نشاط ملحوظ يساري
في الحزب الديمقراطي تجاه مساله اسرائيل
وتحالف الوثيق معها لاحظته اكثر مره حتى
فرد من قابلته مره يتحدث طبعا يتحدث كيف
هذا الامر اليوم يتقدم ويؤثر على قضيتنا
الرئيسيه
هناك تغيرات مهمه تحصل ولكنها طبعا بطيئه
همم وللاسف ابطا من همم التجذر الاستعماري
يعني همم علينا ان نسرع الوتيره في الخارج
ولكن علينا ان نعمل يعني
انا منذ ان دخلت الجامعه ااا وحتى منذ ان
ذهبت الى المدرسه الهاي سكول في بريطانيا
ادركت بان على كل انسان ان يعمل في هذا في
هذا المجال والمجال للعمل مفتوح طبعا في
الغالب تتاثر انت شخصيا انا فقط موقع
اكاديمي مهم في جامعه هارفيل همم في عام
2017 طبعا
عشان نوضح الموضوع الذي ليس بالمفهوم
العام انه بالضروره يكون هناك مؤامره ولكن
ال- ال- الذي حصل طبعا هل هناك اساتذه
صهيونيين في كل جامعه مهمه في الولايات
المتحده
سعيد مع السلامه
همم اتحدث عن همم
الاسعار انه اييه تقاعد استاذ مهم في
التاريخ العربي
وتاريخ الشرق الاوسط اللي هو روجر في تلك
الفتره
وتم فتحه
قدمت اليه هذا من اهم المواقع يعني
الاكاديميه عليها طبعا
قسم قسم التاريخ يعني همم
في تلك الفتره يعني لم اكن انا همم اعمل
على همم تاريخ همم الثوره الفلسطينيه هيك
كنت اعمل على التاريخ يعني والتاريخ
الهجري همم ولكن بالرغم من ذلك همم يعني
وجدوا نشاط السياسي
عندنا مواجهات كبيره يعني همم نشاطك في
المقاطعه طبعا كان عندنا شوف نحنا تورنتو
انتجت اسبوع الفصل العنصري الاسرائيلي
لمواجهه
تؤثر في الغرب تؤثر كثيرا وانا بالواقع
الذي اطلقت هذا هذا الاسم على ذلك الاسبوع
كانت فكرتي ثمانيه
مجموعه من الناس الرائعين يعني نحن نستخدم
هذا الامر بشكل طبعا لكن كان عندنا مجموعه
مميزه جدا وكان عندنا الدكتور احمد شكر
واليوم استاذ كليه ايه
عشان الفكره
فوق عندك انت مؤرخ اسرائيل هناك همم يعني
كان همم انجن لما شاف انه يبدو انه هناك
همم
القسم سوف يصوت عليه وبالتعاون مع مؤرخ
استعماري بريطاني موجود هناك ايضا همم كان
في تلك الفتره همم
اذا كان في اللجنه وقام بارفاق ملحق يقول
به النهار فرد عليها ان تحسب 100 مره قبل
ان يعني تحسب حساباته قبل ان ان شخصا يصف
اسرائيل بدوله عنصريه استعماريه خاصه
في تاثير من قوه صهيونيه كبيره يعني
اسباب همم في في الدول الامريكي ليس من
الصعب علينا نحن ايضا
وانا قمت العربيه
العاده مركز دراسات الشرق الاوسط اول مره
نسمع المركز دراسات عربي شوف انا بدي احكي
لك شغله هيوستن على السيره التطورات
الحاصله هناك مجتمع عربي مميز جدا فيه
يوسف همم
وفكرهم همم كان همم فكره مبنيا على همم
مواجهه اولا تغلغلوا
الاسرائيلي في كل مؤسسه لا علاقه بسرق
الاوسط يعني انت لما تسمي مركز جلسات
الشرق الاوسط اول شيء يقومون به هو
ويسالونك لماذا لا يوجد عندك استاذ يدرس
اسرائيل لماذا لا تروج اسرائيل لماذا لا
تقوم بنشاطات اسرائيل
تجنبا لهذا الجانب رحت العربي طبعا وايضا
العنصر المستهدف في المنطقه في الفتره
الماضيه هو الجانب العربي في المنطقه يعني
هناك اييه ال ال وهذا نتيجه لان الدول
العربيه ضعيفه ومتاكله يعني انت مثلا
عندما تعالج مساله تركيه في الغرب هناك
اداؤه ولكن هناك احترام لتركيا كدوله
كدوله لها تاريخ مستمر وما الى ذلك عندما
تتعامل مع ايران حتى بالرغم هناك برامج
الدراسات الايرانيه بالاضافه الى دراسه
التركيه وايران اقسام الشرق الاوسط
لا يوجد لديك برامج للدراسات العربيه الا
طبعا برنامج جدا مهم ابتدا في جورج ستان
عندما كان
الدكتور هشام سرابي وغيره من ال ال يعني
بصراحه المفكرين العرب المتنورين الذين
لاحظوا ضروره وجود روايه عربيه في في
الولايات المتحده ومقاومه بتاسيس ذلك
المركز ونحن طبعا
هيوستن بجهود كبيره يعني عندنا ناس رائعين
يعني مثلا همم هناك دكتور عزيز الشيباني
هو طبيب ولكن همم شيء اسمه امريكان جاكي
شان ناس مثل يعني من هذا المجتمع العربي
كان لديهم نظره بانه لابد انه اسس شيئا
واستمد تمويله من
المهنيين العرب الموجودين في منطقه
المحليه وهذا اعطاها طابا جميله
وصلنا نهايه الحلقه دكتور كمرخ عربي شاب
المعي في الاربعين ياخذ هذا التجربه اباوت
دقيقه الى اي مدى نقترب من استعاده
تاريخنا واستعاده روايتنا الحقيقيه عن كل
مجرى انا براي هناك عندنا فرصه جميله جدا
لان هناك همم قيادات شابه في العالم في
العالم الاكاديمي التاريخي تظهر من
المنطقه همم
والكثير منهم طبعا ايضا هناك الكثير من
المؤرخات الرائعات بهذا الجيل الشاب
المؤرخين ومؤرخات همم يقومون بعمل همم جدي
وهم يعيدون كتابه تاريخ المنطقه همم حلمي
ان ينتشر هذا النمط ايضا في جامعاتنا
العربيه يعني في الغرب انا انا ارى همم
لم ننجز المهمه بعد همم ولكن همم نحن نمضي
في في طريق جيد بالنسبه لاعاده كتابه
روايه تاريخيه بشكل همم يعني همم يتناسق
همم
طموحات همم
منطقه وتجربتهم همم
وارجو ان ان نرى مثل هذه الحاله في في
جامعتنا المحليه دكتور عبد الرزاق
التكريتي همم الاكاديمي والمؤرخ انا شاكر
جدا لوجودك معنا في المقابله سعيد بن
استمع لهذا الحديث العلمي والتاريخ الهام
وايضا كلنا امل ان يتقدم هذا المشوار بك
وبيضا نخبه المؤرخين الشباب العرب حتى
يعني نخوض او او نقتل الخطوه الاولى في في
عمليه الوعي والتغيير والتاثير على واقعنا
ال- ال- شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا لك استاذ علي
الكلام شكرا لكم على طيب المتابعهم ان شاء
الله في حلقه مقبله انتم بخير السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]